the humanitarian situation in Sudan has
been deteriorating rapidly since
violence broke out to 12 days ago people
say they are running out of food water
and Medicine
we're really suffering grain meals are
closed and we cannot grind our stock of
weed most basic Commodities are absent
and if they are available the prices are
very high
living conditions are very dire for
everyone prices have soared a means of
transportation almost gone people are
really suffering
it's not only Sudanese these rohingya
refugees felt persecution in Myanmar
they now find themselves in the middle
of another conflict
because here our situation is very bad
very heavy fighting
so we are near the rescue
anywhere I need to save some some people
have managed to escape about carrying 1
600 citizens of 50 countries has ducked
in Jeddah in Saudi Arabia and the United
Nations says at least 20 000 people have
arrived in Chad
at the weekend inmates Escape The
Colbert prison in the capital a high
profile detainee who served in former
president Omar al-bashi's government
announced he had left a prison Ahmad
harun is wanted by the international
criminal court and charges of crimes
against humanity in Darfur the Army says
Bashir is being held in the military
Hospital despite this the Army says it's
in control
it is the pride of the Sudanese Army
that we had not touched a single
facility or any infrastructure it is the
rapid support forces that destroyed them
this war will come to an end very soon
and you will listen to the final
statement all of the main facilities are
operational and in order including the
electricity and water supplies
but the rapid support forces posted a
video on social media saying it had
taken over a major oil refinery and
power plant about 70 kilometers from the
Capital
One award we are in full control of the
refinery We Believe In Action not empty
words this is not the time for their
nonsense we control the majority of the
country north south east and west we
have 200 control over Sudan
the United Nations says there is no sign
the warring parties are ready to
negotiate and has warned a further
suffering as long as the fighting
continues Al Jazeera
now these students from other countries
are stuck inside Khartoum and they're
pleading for help
this is an appeal but
then to charity and relieve
relief and to benevolent businessmen we
are living under the brunt of shelling
and gunfire helpless and defenseless we
are left with no options as we have sent
similar messages to our government as
you can see yemeni students are left
with a shelter we've been here almost
like three days with no food with no
water what is this it doesn't make sense
they're supposed to do more than these
were alive we expect them